If there's one question I get asked a lot, it is why do I wear so many dresses...
...or why do I have so many dresses, or why do I love wearing dresses.
Let's start with the first reason: they are comfortable.
A lot of people out there are always talking about how dresses are so uncomfortable...
...and they don't like wearing them...
...and, that is totally fine.
For me, it is what I am most comfortable in.
Just know that I will choose a flowy dress over jeans.
And, when I go shopping for dresses, there are no issues...
...because I already know what works for my body type.
I know what styles I like, what styles look good on me...
...and what styles I feel confident in.
Plus, they're just so much more comfortable.